I'd be maintaining the same body weight
for the past 20 years and I'm finally
going to tell you how
[Music]
if you're a regular hero nobby's kitchen
you know that I've talked a lot about
set point weight aka the weight range
for your body just naturally Falls when
you're not trying to manipulate it so my
body has a very strong set point weight
I'm 35 years old and outside of two
major life events I've weighed the exact
same amount give or take like five
pounds Max since I was around 17. so my
weight did drastically decline for a few
years when I was struggling with my
eating disorder in my late teens and
early 20s and then of course I gained
weight with each of my pregnancies but
between and after these specific times
of flux my body just basically naturally
returned to the exact same weight
obviously my body composition and where
I carry my fat and my muscle has
absolutely changed with each of these
phases of life but the weight itself has
actually been remarkably stable and I
want to make something really clear
first here I actually don't weigh myself
at home like actually ever I did
occasionally I guess during my second
pregnancy only because it was covered
and I didn't get as much prenatal care
but otherwise I do not regularly step on
the scale the only reason I even know
what my weight is is because I get
weight at my physical every year and my
weight stays the same the other really
important thing that I want to mention
is that the set point that I do have is
largely genetic so if you want like a
really short answer to a long long
question as to why I don't gain weight
it's because this is the genetic weight
that I was meant to be but still there
are some things that I do largely kind
of like subconsciously that help me
maintain this homeostasis some of this
is practical advice as a dietitian that
you can take away and incorporate into
your day-to-day some of it is more
nuanced or philosophical and requires
bigger life or mind shifts but none of
these things are hard rules they're just
generally what feels best to me so it's
basically what I normally do and
hopefully some of these gentle nutrition
tips will be helpful for a lot of you at
home and maybe if not you'll at least
get some inspiration for a really tasty
salad let me hop in here super quick to
tell you about my sponsor element so one
of the little supplement tweaks that
I've made to my routine over the past
year has been really focusing in on my
hydration so obviously yes this means
drinking a lot of water but it also is
important to replenish electrolytes too
and I found that I personally feel so
much better when I have my element
electrolytes in the morning so element
is an electrolyte drink mix with no
sugar gluten colors or artificial
ingredients added containing an
evidence-based electrolyte ratio of a
thousand milligram sodium 200 milligrams
potassium and 60 milligrams magnesium
anytime I speak with one of my Rd
colleagues especially those who work in
Sports Nutrition about electrolyte
supplements they all agree that element
is the go-to ensuring I'm keeping on top
of my fluid and electrolyte needs helps
to regulate hormones nutrient absorption
and fluid balance to help to reduce the
risk of headaches muscle cramps and
fatigue and it's not just for exercising
heavily outdoors I depended on these
while I was breastfeeding and if I do
have a drink I always have an election I
drink before bed and even if you're not
doing anything extreme Outdoors some
folks are just what we call Salty
sweaters and they may need some more
electrolytes to feel their best I
personally just feel way more energized
when my electrolytes are properly
balanced my favorite flavor is the
watermelon and also the mango chili if I
need an extra cake to get going in the
morning but right now element is
offering my viewers a free sample pack
with any order so you get eight single
serving packets free with any element
order this is an ideal way to try all
eight flavors or share element with a
salty friend so you can get yours at
drinkelement.com Abby sharp and this
deal is only available if you use my
link so go to
d-r-i-n-k-l-mnt.com Abby Sharp to get
yours today a quick disclaimer and
Trigger warning that we will be
discussing weight and weight loss and I
also want to remind people that it is
completely normal and natural for your
body weight to increase with age your
genetic set point in adulthood will be
different than childhood and Adolescent
so staying the same weight in every
stage of life should never be the goal
number one this one won't be a shocker
to anyone who watches my channel on the
regular but I eat intuitively and
explaining this in its entirety will
take a whole video series which
thankfully I already have for you guys
so we're ahead on that front but in the
context of maintaining my weight I would
say we want to focus on principle 2 and
principle six so that's honor your
hunger and respecting your fullness if
we try to think about our hunger like a
gas gauge generally speaking I like to
start eating around a three-ish and then
stop around like a seven or an eight Max
so post CD it literally took years of me
eating to like a full 10 to feel
confident stopping when I was
comfortable and not not just like
overwhelmingly stuffed and what helped
me to get there was coming to terms with
how bad I physically feel when I
chronically overeat so for me it messes
up my sleep I get a big blood sugar
crash in the middle of night I feel
constipated like I really just don't
feel my best and making that my reason
to stop at a more comfortable place
rather than the fear of gaining weight
has really helped to keep me out of
scarcity mentality and also just made it
a lot easier for me to more effortlessly
choose portions that maintain my weight
number two this is a lot more specific
but I generally don't drink a lot of
calories so I don't drink soda I don't
really even drink a lot of fancy boozy
juices anymore I mean smoothies are more
of like a solid food to me so that's a
different category I do have a lot of
smoothies so the only legitimate
exceptions I have on the regular is an
occasional glass of wine and my daily
lattes because no one should touch or
change how they like their coffee and
also black copies for psychopaths just
kidding but yeah this is generally why I
use soy milk in my coffee in the morning
because a I just like the flavor of soy
and B I like that I'm getting a little
bit of balancing protein in there to
complement and contribute to my
breakfast as opposed to just straight up
sugars in a glass of juice and speaking
of drinks let's talk about booze for a
second so I don't drink that much
honestly I love wine but I drink Max two
to three drinks a week and this is
mainly because alcohol just does not
feel great to me again kind of like
overeating it makes me a bit constipated
it up my sleep I sometimes get
like a bit of a blood sugar crash in the
middle of the night or the next morning
so yeah this is my non-diet culture
rationale for me to not refill my glass
which to me is far more motivating than
weight loss or fear of gaining weight
but limiting my booze also inadvertently
also limits a lot of calories so you
know a standard glass of wine or beer
has I don't know like 120 150 calories
if you're doing that every single night
it does add up I would always find when
people cut out booze they would quickly
lose a good amount of weight especially
men who are used to drinking like two
beers a night I move my body pretty much
every day and if you're thinking oh my
God that's excessive I can never do that
it's not like I'm doing a two-hour
Olympic gym workout seven days a week
basically I do four days or so of
purposeful exercise strength training
Pilates bar style workouts Etc and then
the rest of the time I do a lot of
walking like I live in downtown Toronto
so my Mantra is if I can walk I'm gonna
walk because often traffic and parking
is such a nightmare so frustrating you'd
get there way faster if you just moved
your body I'm also a natural fidgeter
which may or may not be undiagnosed ADHD
but we also know that fidgeting is
linked to a lower set point weight okay
number five ate a large salad pretty
much every day when I had sibo I
couldn't eat salad without blowing up
like a balloon and I love salad like I
love the crunch I love a really good
bright Zippy dressing like the one I
just made oh my gosh so good so I
definitely desperately missed my salad
but once I fully recovered from my sibo
I really found that getting in one
consistent big bowl of raw veggies and
like all the top things really helped
with regularity which is really
important for sibo prevention and also
helps with satiety because of the volume
and the fiber and this is not a rule
like I said none of these things are
rules some days I have very little or no
vegetables altogether but I also just
know that without veggies in my day I do
not feel my best I feel it the next day
my whole bathroom routine gets up
number six I eat protein at every meal
and snack protein is King of the satiety
hierarchy and we have so much research
on the benefits for weight management so
I really do try to aim for like a solid
20 to 30 grams per meal that's my
typical goal and around 100 grams per
day I don't actually measure anything or
count anything I just know based on my
satiety cues now and general kind of
eyeballing portion sizes and it sounds
like a lot but it's not that hard to hit
so you know that could mean some protein
notes at breakfast it could mean like a
chicken salad at lunch some fish with
some veggies and carbs for dinner a big
bowl of cottage cheese and some nuts and
and fruit and stuff for for bedtime
snack like it's all there for me I don't
really have to put that much work into
Meeting those needs number seven I
typically only eat out around twice a
week and again never really do the
calories or the risk or fear of gaining
weight crossed my mind as a reason to
avoid going out very often like I was
there when I had an ed if someone were
to invite me to go out for dinner I
would full-blown panic like full out
Panic Googling all the nutrition facts
and the menu Etc I know a lot of you
guys have been there too now I just
mindfully limit my dining out because a
my kids don't like it when we go out
they freak out as soon as I'm wearing
something other than a house coat my son
says are you going out for dinner and he
starts to get all teary-eyed so I would
never want to leave him multiple times a
week but also the combination of the
booze and a big heavy meal and a late
night definitely means my sleep gets
up also what is going on with
restaurant prices these days like it is
getting out of control to eat anywhere
you can't even go to a Boston Pizza when
I do eat out I still try to keep my
Hunger crushing combo top of mind so
I'll build on top of whatever it is that
I'm craving so let's say I wanted a big
pool of pasta or mac and cheese or pizza
or something I would probably start with
a side salad or make sure there was
veggies in the side or something like
that I would do some kind of protein up
like seafood and obviously I would still
be eating more calories than had I made
that meal at home but again this is not
an everyday thing honestly folks life is
too damn short and speaking of
restaurant food I try to incorporate
what I call Smart use of oils so I like
teaching smart use of oils because
saying moderate use of oils is pretty
ambiguous and saying lemon oils or avoid
oils really risks us falling into
scarcity mentality so smart use of oils
to me is all about about utilizing oils
where they are most useful and
functional so no offense to Europeans
but I don't finish every dish with like
a big big drizzle of olive oil when I've
already cooked in olive oil I just add
enough oil to coat the pan while cooking
usually like a tablespoon or so and then
with dressings I usually do like half
oil half vinegar personally I just
prefer a nice Zippy bright vinaigrette
and then I fill in the rest of the gaps
with like lots of mustard a little bit
of Maple in there maybe some fresh herbs
or a little shallot action so tasty and
then when I get salads out I usually ask
for the dressing on the side and again
in my head this is less about the
calories as it is just a general
preference like there's nothing I hate
more than getting a big glob of dressing
on my green so I usually like to add it
in layers and then I eat that layer and
then I add a little bit more Etc also I
like to consider the smart function in
specific salads so in a salad that has
like a lot of cheese or avocado for
example you know once it mushes up it
tends to coat the leaves in some of
those healthy oils and fats so I also
find that it just generally needs less
dressing than if you had something that
was just straight up heavy leaves so
this to me is just a really smart way to
utilize an ingredient that does
contribute to satiety satisfaction and
nutrition but I do think there's a sweet
spot if weight management is also a goal
number nine I have pulled a lot of time
and resources into my sleep and Stress
Management as many of you guys know if
you follow me here I have been an
insomniac for many years and I mean I
guess I still am I'm just heavily
medicated so most nights I sleep
decently well and you know my journey
with anxiety has also been a really big
struggle in my life but I would say with
a combination of like therapy medication
meditation I have been managing so much
better and we know that a lack of sleep
and excess stress are associated with
higher body weight and weight weight
gain and I will say that during what I
call my dark days of my insomnia I
definitely was a little bit fluffier and
I naturally ended up leaning out when I
started medicating which makes total
sense because my cortisol was completely
dysregulated and I was getting up in the
middle of the night and having like a
full meal at 2 A.M because I was awake
and I was bored and eventually I would
get hungry so achieving my personal
health homeostasis definitely
contributed to my weight homeostasis at
number 10 I have prioritized my gut
health so we know that gut bacteria
diversity is associated with body weight
and risk of weight gain over time
basically the type of bacteria in your
gut affects how calories are extracted
and absorbed and we also know that fiber
like in things like salads is a very key
player because it feeds our good gut
bacteria now as we've established I eat
a lot of plant-based Foods usually got
fruit at breakfast and snack and salad
at lunch and cooked veggies at dinner
and I try to aim for plant-based protein
at least two to three times per day I
also eat a lot of fermented foods like
yogurt have that basically every day and
I take a combination of different
probiotic supplements like Spore based
bacillus strains and I get a lot of
questions all the time about my sibo it
is gone I am cured I'm regular I'm happy
and my gut has never been better so just
reiterate these are the things that I do
in my life that as a dietitian I know
can help to contribute to the
maintenance of my very very narrow set
point weight that and
which is genetics but the key here is
that I don't do any of these things
intentionally to lose weight or out of
fear of gaining weight I do them because
they make me feel good and in hindsight
I can see yes they do play a role in me
managing my weight but if that was my
only intention I would for sure find
myself in this kind of restrict binge or
pen repeat cycle that not only doesn't
support weight loss it also likely
causes weight gain so the moral of the
story here is that getting to this place
is a journey it actually took me over 10
years of me still grappling with guilt
to morality and scarcity while making
choices that didn't really feel good to
my body to finally make choices from a
place of genuine self-care but I got
myself a big salad here folks so if you
guys like this video please let me know
give me the thumbs up let me know in the
comments below what other gentle
nutrition tips will be helpful for you
also if you're looking for Hunger
crushing combo ideas hit out my
description I have the free Hunger crush
and combo ebook ready to go you guys can
download that today and I'll see you
next time on Abby's kitchen bye